[Musique]
or ces personnages racontent une très
belle histoire une très belle histoire
d'amour qui est un moment tourner au
drame qui se finit bien c'est le prince
de fanta et si ça coûte à la
[Musique]
un cadre qui rejoindra t fait alors elle
est faite en plâtre mais au départ
camille a réalisé un petit projet de 15
cm de haut tu vois ce fait les gars de
mon doigt un autre de 20 cm et elle a
réalisé en terre après la ferme où l'âge
et à partir du moulage on a obtenu ce
plâtre d'accord et ce plâtre elle va
donner une couleur elle va donner une
couleur très très brune pour donner
l'impression que c'était un prince parce
qu'en fait travailler un bon ça coûte
très cher
[Musique]
cette pièce elle a été malmenée pendant
presque cent ans elle est arrivée
achetons c'était l'ancien musée
à cette époque là on noterait pas
beaucoup de personnages nus ou tout au
moins
des personnages réalisée par une artiste
femme sa part et c'est inconvenant pas
bien il s'est dit choqué parce que
c'était un couple nu et en plus c'était
l'oeuvre d'une femme et surtout oser
représenter des personnages nus c'était
scandaleux alors ses premières grandes
oeuvres de jeunesse et kamin avec 24 ans
quand elle a fait 7 heures et ce qui est
exceptionnel c'est que quand elle
réalise cette oeuvre
elle a déjà toute sa puissance toute la
force d'un grand sculpteur et quand elle
a eu 15 ans 16 ans elle été remarqué par
un sculpteur
il s'appelait alfred boucher qui
habitaient le même petit pays qu'elle et
qui lui a dit oh mais mademoiselle c'est
fantastique et il a aidé il a dû partir
en italie et il a demandé au grand
sculpteur auguste rodin de prendre comme
élève annoncé mme clinton
les gens vont un peu con fond est ce que
c'est une oeuvre de claudel est ce que
c'est une oeuvre de rodin et par la
suite qu'elle y sera
désolé parce qu'elle aura le sentiment
qu'on assimile toujours qu'on a reconnu
pas elle mais quand on connaît toujours
monsieur renard
alors quand on parle de sa compta là
c'est extraordinaire parce que là tu as
sous les yeux une pièce unique
il y en a pas d'autre il n'y a pas eu de
moulage de fait alors que l'abandon par
exemple qui est un bronze
il ya eu plusieurs moulage de fait c'est
à dire qu'on a fait une série alors que
la cette pièce n'a qu'une seule et le
musée cetto tulle a devant les yeux
[Musique]